da sind jetzt zehn Gewinner was wünschen
sie denen ich wünsche Ihnen ein
besonderes Erlebnis das werden Sie mit
Sicherheit haben es sind ja bis auf
einen lauter Gewinnerinnen und Gewinner
die noch nie mit einem Hubschrauber
geflogen sind und dann gleich einmal mit
einem mit einem Black Hawk also ich bin
überzeugt davon dass wird für jeden und
jeder ein besonderes Erlebnis werden
hallo mein Name ist Dorothea
sauber fliegen und ich freue mich schon
sehr bin schon sehr gespannt was ich von
oben alles sehen werde hallo
definitiv nur dann vom Bundesheer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr super
eine coole Erfahrung ja
keine Angst
[Gelächter]
Erlebnis gerne mal wieder
für mich auch gerne mal wieder und wie
schnell das schon vorbei war viel zu
schnell ja wir wollen wir zurück
das war echt super das erste Mal aber
echt toll
was sehr cool
gerne wieder Danke schön danke schön
[Musik]